cancer is the change of what was once
upon a time in normal cell interest cell
which grows in pelipper it's in an
uncontrolled fashion every normal cell
has a blueprint a DNA code that normally
tells it how to behave and if that DNA
code a blueprint becomes changed or
mutated the nut can lead to genes
running amok and I can lead to the cell
growing in a completely uncontrolled
fashion and lab is in essence accounts
herself malignant melanoma is a special
type of skin cancer we all have within
our skin cells called melanocytes and
these are cells that normally produce
pigment or color for example when we go
into the Sun sunlight is harmful to our
skin so normally these melanocytes will
produce a brown pigment what we call a
time which helps protect us from this
ultraviolet to this radiation and
unfortunately if you're exposed to too
much sunlight or ultraviolet radiation
then these melanocytes can accumulate
mutations or damage in DNA that means
mulana site the normal Milano site
becomes a cancer cell when it becomes a
cancer cell we call it a melanoma some
patients who get melanoma on their skin
can have it successfully excise by a
surgeon or it will never come back but
I'm quite a significant number of
patients even when it's excised it comes
back a couple of years later and when
melanomas come back they are invariably
fatal up until about two years ago we
would have treated a melanoma patient of
largely surgery if the counsellor was
only on the skin and if the cancer had
spread we would have used to
chemotherapy but only about 10% of
patients responded what we discovered
that the Sanger Institute about five or
six years ago was that in about half of
the cases of melanoma skin cancer the
melanoma is essentially harboring a
mutation or DNA mistake in a very
specific gene not gene is called B Roth
and having that mutation in V Roth
essentially gives the melanoma cancer
cell constant acceleration scientists
find that b-raf was significant in
melanoma by essentially sequencing large
numbers of these cancers using
technology has been developed over the
last
years on an essence when you sequence a
large number of any counts so you can
simply ask what are the most frequent
abnormalities or mutations we see and I
done verbally tells you what's important
to the cancer and in this case in
melanoma we find that up to half of
melanoma had a mutation in the gene
b-raf these particular mutations in
melanoma are its Achilles heel and if we
use a new drug a brand new treatment in
these patients
the response rate goes from 10 percent
to 70 percent
Oh